hi this is Startalk radio mike massimino
sitting in for Neil deGrasse Tyson with
Chuck knifes
a man we're talking about the movie
gravity and fielding questions from our
online social media resources that's
right that's right so let's jump right
into it and all these questions are
pretty much tailored to you so there
must be easy ones right so what you're
saying even an astronaut knows this
stuff you don't have Neil here with the
big brain but we've got an astronaut who
can do his best here's the thing no
matter who is in this studio I am always
the person with the least amount of
accomplishments Oh cut it out don't lie
to the people I'm used to come on now
all right here we go this is from Rachel
McClelland and Rachel says I haven't
seen the movie
Oh oops sorry Rachel you're about to be
very desired no haven't seen the movie
but just the trailer for the TV
advertisements it seemed as though there
was noise when everything was crashing
around and falling to pieces I thought
there was no sound in space am I wrong
no one can hear you scream yes that's
the that is it is true when you're
outside in a vacuum because sound needs
a medium to travel along it's like so
weird they can people can hear us now
because they're listening on the radio
correct and we're using electronics to
broadcast our voice if if we did not
have that they would not be able to hear
us and we can talk across the room
because the atmosphere gives us a medium
to try out with that for the sound of
traveling in space since there's no
there's no atmosphere there's no air if
you bang on something while you're doing
your spacewalk you will not be able to
hear that the only noise you can hear is
internal in your suit because you have
atmosphere in your suit so the noise of
your suit there's a hum of a fan noise
you can hear that which is good because
if it stops you know something's wrong
with the spacesuit and anything that
comes across your headset like the
headsets we're wearing we can hear that
and that's what happens because it's
electronic it's electronic right so you
need a medium for that sound to travel
along and so now you don't have it so
here is a
weird question then this would be more
of a WWN s what whitneyhl say ah
question I thought it was a wrestling
thing no this is my W ns all right okay
let's say you're in the vacuum yeah
forget the pressure yeah okay right go
alive you're still alive somehow suspend
disbelief that way I got feels gonna be
good whatever you sum up fill your lungs
with air yep
you hold it right you go out into space
into the vacuum now how do you go like
this Wow would you be able to hear that
no what you would hear probably
something internal you would hear
whatever noise is being reverberate it
inside of you whatever that is but the
actual projection of that sound would
not reach it would not resolve anything
that's internal you would hear this is
interesting because you probably hear
something because you're making noise
within your body okay but that noise
we're now projected here that would be
that would be probably good question to
follow up with Neil I wish he was here
but since he's not I can make it up
that's my theory all right all right yo
that's it that's that's pretty cool then
what one interesting thing related you
can't you don't hear you can can't hear
whistle in space when you're doing a
spacewalk either because it's not enough
atmosphere for the vibration the
vibration to have to work so while you
work with your space you can't whistle
I'm more related so now how about this
have you ever tried I'm speaking to your
own person have you ever tried to hit
something in space just to try it out to
see hang it yeah well actually I've made
a lot of noises that I haven't heard and
I wouldn't say I did it on purpose right
but yeah there have been things that
I've had to break and things that I've
knocked into and I haven't heard a thing
it's one funny thing is when you're
inside the spaceship you can hear people
banging around in the airlock right
so they don't hear into that they're in
there making a racket you know removing
tools around and banging into stuff and
your UPS it's like you know you're
upsetting the kids that you have are
making a racket that right who's making
that noise what's going on but they
don't hear anything they're banging
stuff left and right but you can hear
that because the sound is traveling
through the ship oh my god the reverse
of that would be every parent's dream
yes Ithaca I think it's better to hear
what's going on though
all right cool well there you have it
Rachel there's your answer it's
Hollywood magic that's why you're
hearing things thanks Chuck this is Mike
Massimino sitting in for Neil deGrasse
Tyson and thank you for listening to
Startalk radio